the American Medical Association pursues
an anti-science agenda
Yale students invaded the Yale Harvard
football game and Michael Bloomberg
officially enters the race I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show the
Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a VPN
yet visit expressvpn dot-com slash bet
and make the magic happen okay so I want
to begin today with a non impeachment
related story that's because frankly I'm
tired of the impeachment stuff I don't
think it's going anywhere we'll get to
those updates in a little bit but the
media is outsized attention to
impeachment is obscuring the fact that
there's some deep systemic change going
on in the United States with with regard
particularly to hot button social issues
and a lot of this is being pushed by
folks who have an anti science agenda
inside the scientific community today's
example it's actually coming from last
week so late last week the American
Medical Association according to the AMA
website gathered physician and medical
student leaders from all corners of
medicine at its interim meeting to shape
guiding policies on emerging health care
topics ooh the AMAs House of Delegates
is the policymaking body at the center
of American medicine the policies
adopted by the House of Delegates today
this would been last week like last
Wednesday Thursday included quote the
AMA supports state and federal bans on
conversion therapy now let me be clear
before I go any further when it comes to
conversion therapy no one no one is in
favor of electrocuting kids in order to
make them not gay no one is talking
about that no one is in favor of
electroshock therapy for kids who are
suffering from gender identity disorder
or gender dysphoria however you decide
to use that term when the AMA talks
about conversion therapy they're talking
about your ability to bring your child
to a psychologist and the psychologist
being able to tell your child that your
child is in fact the sexes to which he
or she belongs that's what the AMA is
talking about they want to ban that hey
that's what they're saying explicitly
the AMA now wants to develop models
state legislation and advocate for
federal legislation to ban so-called
reparative or conversion therapy for
sexual orientation or gender identity so
not just with regard to you have a kid
who's 12 thinks he is sexually confused
about his orientation and you want to
take him to a therapist and the
therapist might be able to help him
clarify some of those feelings or might
be able to help your kid
out of the struggle without telling them
that they are explicitly gay for example
not only banning that right not only
banning that and not just banning it for
adults but not just betting for children
banning it for adults right so what the
left would like is for there to be for
there to be taxpayer sponsored sex
changes but if you are 21 years old and
you are bothered by your sexual
orientation want to talk to a
psychologist it would be illegal for the
psychologist to talk to you about this
in any way other than to affirm that you
are indeed gay but we're not just thing
about homosexuality here or sexual
orientation we are talking specifically
about gender identity so you bring your
five-year-old to a psychologist because
your five-year-old is expressing that
they believe that they are a member of
the opposite sex
the AMA wants to ban the psychologist
from telling your kid that your kid is
actually a member of the sex to which
they belong so you bring your
five-year-old son to the doctor because
your five-year-old son keeps maintaining
he as a girl the AMA wants to ban any
therapy that does not say that your kid
is a girl that's what the American
Medical Association hey this is not
science as we will see according to the
AMA the support for legislative bans
strengthens AMAs long-standing
opposition to this unscientific practice
first of all let's just be frank about
this there's not a lot of evidence with
regard to the various therapies that
have been applied with regard to gender
identity disorder or gender dysphoria as
we'll get to the AMA heard testimony
including first-hand accounts regarding
these specific harms triggered by
conversion therapy including depression
post-traumatic stress disorder and
suicidal thoughts and attempts am a
board member William Kobler MD said it
is clear to the AMA that the conversion
therapy needs to end in the United
States given the deliberate risk of harm
to LGBTQ people conversion therapy has
no foundation as scientifically valid
medical care and lacks credible evidence
to support its efficacy or safety hey
now again they want to make sure that if
you bring your child to a doctor because
your your child is expressing gender
confusion when I'm talking sexual
orientation any more gender confusion
that that would be illegal across the
country across the country which by the
way is the first step toward folks on
the social left suggesting that if you
are a parent and you and your child goes
to school and expresses that they're
confused about gender and you don't
affirm that your child's the member of
the opposite gender that you are in fact
a derelict parents and Child Protective
Services comes for you right this is the
direction we are moving and we are
moving there
quickly with the support of
organizations like the AMA which are
cutting directly against science when I
say they are cutting directly against
science I mean they're cutting directly
against science because what exactly is
the basis for this suggestion that that
quote-unquote conversion therapy meaning
talk therapy with your kid is not only
ineffective but counterproductive it is
one study and one study alone and the
study happens to be junk science it is
one study and it is politically driven
and it is junk science and the AMA is
using that to say that your psychologist
can't engage in what basically is
cognitive behavioral therapy with your
kid cognitive behavioral therapy by the
way is basically the only form of
psychology that is known to work the
basic theory of cognitive behavioral
therapy CBT is that you as a person you
have thoughts which leads to feelings
which leads to actions and when it comes
to fighting depression what
psychologists typically do is they teach
you to disconnect thoughts feelings and
actions so your thoughts should not
necessarily be feeling some those
feelings shouldn't necessarily lead to
actions basically the AMA wants to ban
that with regard to children with regard
to children who are experiencing gender
confusion who may not understand the
difference between boy and girl and
they're basing this all on one study
basically one study and they're open
about this they're basing it on one
study completely that study was the
study published in the journal JAMA
psychiatry okay and the study is just
garbage I'll explain in just one second
first let's talk for a second about
getting ready for work in the morning so
you want shaving to be super simple
right you want everything there in front
of you but how often do you run out of
the product that you're looking for in
the morning you know like oh gosh you
know I got to go over to the drugstore
and I got to pick up what I need well
what if all of that were just available
easily to you you know like on your
nightstand is ready to go right right
there in the bathroom well this is where
Dollar Shave Club comes in when I talk
about Dollar Shave Club I can't stress
enough the quality of their products
they spent years developing crafting and
refining everything they have everything
I used to look feel and smell my best
you name it they've got it
and I use it I've been in Dollar Shave
Club member for years I love their amber
lavender body cleanser it is soothing it
is wonderful they've got the aftershave
that really smells terrific they've got
everything right Dollar Shave has he
covered from head to toe literally
they've got everything you need to
shower shave style your hair brush your
teeth and more Dollar Shave Club can
keep you automatically stock
on the products you use you get what you
what you want whenever you need it
whether that's once a month or a few
times a year as a Dollar Shave Club
member I know what I'm getting is the
highest quality and right now you can
put the quality of Dollar Shave club's
products to the test their ultimate
shades starter set has basically
everything you need for an amazing shave
they've got the executive razor the
shave butter the prep scrout the post
shave do they got it all man the best
part is you can try it for just five
bucks after that the restock box shuts
regular size products with regular
prices get that ultimate starter set for
just $5 at dollarshaveclub.com slash pen
that is dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben
okay so as I say the American Medical
Association on the basis of a literally
one study is now calling for a
nationwide ban on what they call
conversion therapy and the very term
conversion therapy is an attempt to
conflate bad old conversion therapy
meaning like people being electroshock
when people thought they were gay right
which no one is for again for the fifth
time this show with the basic idea that
if I bring my kids to the doctor my kid
has gender confused that the doctor is
allowed to tell them that they are
actually their genetic self right that
they are actually a boy or they're
actually a girl the AMA wants to ban
that outright they want a federal ban on
that from the federal government and
they're basing this on one study and the
study is done by an activist of course
because nothing in this area has
anything to do with science right the
person who released the study is a guy
named Jack turban he's lead author Jack
Durban happens to be an activist on this
issue and he states openly that the
study was done in order to prove a case
that he already believed turbine claims
that the study was quote the first study
to show that gender identity conversion
efforts are associated with adverse
mental health outcomes including suicide
attempts and the previous reports
showing the negative effects of
conversion therapy have focused on
efforts to change a person's sexual
orientation rather than gender identity
and then turban turned to its political
and legal value said this is important
because some experts continue to
advocate for gender identity conversion
efforts for young children it's not a
conversion it's not a conversion hey you
are what you are
unlike sexual orientation where your
feelings are the actual thing at issue
when it comes to gender identity what
does it issue is that your feelings are
at odds with your actual biology right
is a very different thing chat sexual
orientation and gender identity are not
the same in a variety of ways including
the fact that gender identity
is inextricably connected with your
biology and your biology is reflected in
your gender identity and pretending that
when the two are at odds that this is
not a big problem is ridiculous when it
comes to sexual orientation again your
feelings are your feelings but they are
not at odds with your biology okay when
your gender when your when you are
saying that your identity is in direct
conflict with your biological sex that
is not a conversion attempt to say your
biological sex exists and you need to
change your thinking about your
biological sex that's absurd it Turban
said we hope our findings contribute to
ongoing legislative efforts to ban
gender identity conversion efforts in
other words the study was done
explicitly with this goal in mind and as
it turns out like many studies that are
done with the specific end in mind the
study happens to be a piece of crap it
was published with vast coverage in the
media just last week in the Jay in the
or in September in the JAMA
the journal JAMA psychiatry these were
researchers affiliated with Harvard
University and Massachusetts General
Hospital they also happen to be
professionals who are associated deeply
with the LGBTQ cause they're a bunch of
problems with the study and there's a
good deconstruction of the study by a
professor of sociology named Mark
Regnerus the biggest problem with the
study is that it is a self-defined
survey in other words it's an opt-in a
so is a survey that went out to a bunch
of people who are deliberately
identified as people who had
relationships with transgender with
transgender causes so it's basically
like sending a survey to activists in
other words it is non representative and
not only is it not representative it
misses the entire point and misses the
entire point because if you send a
survey out to people who identify as
transgender and you ask them whether a
quote-unquote transgender conversion
therapy worked for them when they were
kids or whether it was damaging what do
you think they're going to say that's
like sending out a survey to a bunch of
divorced adults and asking them how
marriage therapy went and whether it's
useful or whether it made them feel bad
their divorce you would imagine that
marriage therapy made them feel bad it's
ridiculous I mean it's like sending out
a survey to people who have had a
recurrence of cancer and asking them
whether chemo made them feel bad or
whether it helped them yes well once you
know they've had a recurrence of cancer
then the chemo didn't help them all that
much did it
okay well the problem
this for a huge huge number of kids who
experience gender confusion at some
point in their young lives they grow out
of it like 80% of kids who experience
gender confusion when they're five six
years old grow out of it and that's
low-end estimates anywhere from fifty to
eighty percent at the low-end none of
those kids got surveyed none of these
people got surveyed instead you surveyed
the people who are most likely to
identify as depressed and upset and are
openly identifying as transgender what
do you think they're gonna say when they
said they saw a psychologist who said to
them that they were a member of their
original sex it's an absurd survey on
its face not just that as Regnerus
points out the study fails to define or
even distinguish what it even means by
gender identity conversion therapy right
that conversion efforts it comes from a
solitary question respondents were asked
quote did any professional such as a
psychologist counselor or religious
adviser try to make you identify only
with your sex assigned at Birth in other
words try to stop you being trans that's
the survey question ok so that is
literally anyone who did not just give
you perfect affirmation of the idea that
you were a member of the sex to which
you were claiming identity and they're
saying that that in isn't enough attempt
damaging so anybody who once said to you
know you know what you're not a woman
you're a man that was conversion therapy
under this particular definition Steven
Levine psychiatrist in long time gender
identity expert highlights the quandary
facing professionals attempting to
counsel transgender patients on the
biological social and psychological
risks posed by any treatment approach
such risks are real and ought to be
discussed but if you do give somebody
ethical informed consent then that is
trying to stop you from being friends in
other words if you say to somebody
listen if you actually want to commit a
surgery where you where you mutilate
your genitals I mean that is what the
surgery does that is gonna carry with it
certain risks it's going to be a very
hard process it's gonna carry with it
certain medical risks if you say that
that could be seen as gender identity
conversion therapy under this survey as
Regnerus points out the authors of the
JAMA psychiatry study following the u.s.
tss survey measurements aren't
interested in subtleties the authors
paint an entire class of cautious
therapeutic approaches as intrinsically
harmful sending a clear message to
psychiatrist and psychotherapist alike
scientifically we learn nothing of the
respondents motivations for interacting
with the profession
in the first place you don't even know
whether people were depressed going in
and depressed coming out
also as Regnerus points out the data
come from a non-random opt-in survey the
UST s that only targeted networked
self-identified transgender or
non-binary persons by advertising their
survey among active transgender LG LG BT
Q and allied organizations which again
is not only a non-random sample you are
specifically targeting people for whom
the therapy did not work right i mean
that is again the base point here if you
keep targeting people for whom a therapy
didn't work and ask them whether the
therapy is harmful or helpful they will
of course tell you that the therapy is
harmful but this is not a representative
cross-section in fact it's not even a
representative cross-section of
transgender people as Regnerus points
out when compared with the 2017 study of
the demographic characteristics of
transgender adults from the CDC's at
behavioral risk factor surveillance
system which is a population-based
sample the USGS respondents are really
dissimilar they've doubled the
unemployment rate they have doubled the
number of male to female identity
I mean yet almost triple actually triple
only 18% are married versus 50% in the
BRFSS so it's a completely non
representative sample and you can't
weight the sample because again the
sample is the sample and that's the poll
results that's like taking a poll of
only Republicans asking how they feel
about Obama and then weighting the
sample it doesn't help you at all
also the the study then builds on
dubious perceptions of
representativeness by reporting
confidence intervals which is just
nonsense in sociological terms that only
works for probability samples but this
is not a probability sample so that
makes no sense at all and then of course
the authors are not interested in
putting their implied causation to the
test
instead a substitute of injustice has
committed against the respondents
infuses the study suggesting a decidedly
external locus of control in the lives
of transgender Americans the narrative
is interrupted only once when the
authors admit that it is possible that
those with worst mental health are
internalized transphobia may have been
more likely to seek out conversion
therapy rather than non conversion
therapy suggesting conversion efforts
themselves were not causative but
apparently that's not worth considering
beyond that one line in the study on the
basis of this one single
garbage study the entire AMA just voted
it was actually a small section of the
AMA but now it represents the entire AMA
decided to vote in favor of pushing
federal legislation bandung banning
psychologists and psychiatrists from
informing children that they are in fact
the sex of their birth hey this is not
only non-scientific it is politically
driven crap and it's incredibly
dangerous we get to more of this in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that it is open enrollment season
it is indeed open enrollment season and
that means that it is time for you to
look up into life insurance you're a
responsible adult right well but when
you look it up through your employer
here's the problem you're probably only
got like one tenth what you need what
you actually need is a better life
insurance policy that actually is inside
your employer and this is where policy
genius can help policy genius is the
easy way to shop for a life insurance
plan that is not tied to your job in
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find your best price once
you apply the policy genius team will
handle all the paperwork and the red
tape the life insurance you buy through
policy genius does stay with you
even if you leave your job when policy
genius doesn't just make it easy to get
life insurance they can also help you
fight in the run right home and auto
insurance disability insurance as well
so when you're looking at your workplace
at benefits this month make sure to
double check your life insurance options
then head on over to policy genius calm
to get quotes and apply in minutes
policy genius it's the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance go check
them out at policy genius calm again be
an adult make sure you get the life
insurance your family needs and auto
insurance and home insurance and
disability insurance you need over a
policy genius calm or competitive
shopping help
competitive shopping helps you policy
genius.com okay now this has been a
longtime trend unfortunately with regard
to political hot-button issues in the
American Psychiatric Association which
produces the Diagnostic and Statistical
Manual of Mental Disorders for example
and in the AMA is politics driving
medicine and not the other way around
this is why the dsm-5 reclassified
gender identities assort disorder not as
gender identity disorient it gender
dysphoria based on no evidence by the
way nothing changed about the diagnosis
of gender identity disorder instead they
simply listed it as gender dysphoria and
then they acknowledged in the dsm-5 why
they did this they said it was to remove
stigma right they said when it comes to
access to care
many of the treatment options for this
condition include counseling cross-sex
hormones
reassignment surgery and social and
legal transition to the desired gender
to get insurance coverage for the
medical treatments individuals to need a
diagnosis in other words they're even
saying that if it had been up to them
politically they would have removed
gender dysphoria as a diagnosis at all
from the dsm-5 which is insane so you
walk into the doctor and you say listen
I feel like a lady today I feel like a
natural woman and the doctor is supposed
to go perfectly normal everything's good
but just so we can make sure that you're
covered by your insurance we'll call it
gender dysphoria but really there's
nothing wrong with you unless you get
depressed because of your gender
dysphoria they say part of removing
stigma is about choosing the right words
replacing disorder with dysphoria in the
diagnostic label is not only more
appropriate and consistent with familiar
clinical sexology terminology it also
removes the connotation the patient is
disordered but of course your gender
identity is disordered ultimately the
changes regarding gender dysphoria in
dsm-5 respect the individuals identified
by offering a diagnostic name that is
more appropriate to the symptoms and
behavior they experience without
jeopardizing their access to effective
treatment options there is literally no
evidence that gender identity disorder
is not a disorder all of this was just
determined by a bunch of politically
active people inside the APA and you've
seen the same thing inside the AMA now
why does all of this matter because the
goal in all of this is to use science as
a lever in order to bully parents this
is where this is going right the
headlines on that original study that I
talked about which is again a garbage
study has serious serious flaws with it
here is the study from the Washington
Post headline conversion therapy
associated with severe psychological
discrepant transgender people study says
science magazine news study reveals
risks of transgender conversion therapy
New York Daily News trans adults who try
professional help to change gender
identity are twice as likely to commit
suicide new study finds except that the
study was again flawed from the outset
it was specifically based on people for
whom the therapy had obviously failed it
did not survey anyone who had previously
identified as trans and grew out of it
which again is up to 80% of people who
had some form of sexual identity
confusion meaning gender identity
confusion it's absolute nonsense okay
but based on this based on this
apparently apparently that
enough to change the entire medical
diagnosis of a specific subset and then
the goal is going to be exactly what it
has been for years again it's not going
to stop with your kid has a problem and
you can't bring them to a psychologist
or a psychiatrist to get some even even
watchful waiting right there there are a
few different treatments that are that
have been considered here one is the
overt rejection no this is not true the
second is watchful waiting which is you
don't affirm the chosen quote/unquote
gender of the child instead you just say
listen we're gonna wait on this and
we're gonna help you through whatever
pain you're experiencing and then we'll
see if you grow out of it or you don't
that itself could be classified as
gender conversion therapy instead the
left only one's gender affirmation only
gender affirmation and they will push
this through okay the way this will work
is that eventually as soon as a kid goes
to a public school and the public school
here is that your kid is saying that
they are a member of the opposite sex
and the kid comes home and you say no
you're not you're a boy if you're a boy
or boy and your kid goes back to school
they'll call CPS on you that is where
this is moving there's a great piece in
National Review about all of this latest
issue of nationally by Madeleine Kearns
called the tragedy of the trans child
and she talks specifically about the
ridiculousness of where all of this
started she says humans are sexually
dimorphic species females produce eggs
and bear offspring males produce
permanent pregnant females the existence
of disorders of sexual development or
more precisely and potentially
offensively intersex persons and the
need for greater social understanding of
them in no way collapses this
distinction in the 1950s the
relationship between the terms sex and
gender the latter of which applied to
chiefly to grammar began to change as
sexologist coined the phrase date gender
identity to denote the sex that one
believed one was and then of course
there was a very famous case in the
1960s where a psychologist named John
money conducted a twin study in which a
male baby Bruce rhymer with a damaged
penis was raised as a girl his brother
Brian was raised as a boy money
instructed the parents to raise their
children to believe that Bruce was
really a girl called Brenda to make a
long story short both brothers ended up
killing themselves I mean that that is
not particularly surprising given the
fact that biology is biology the fact is
that children cannot make rational
decisions not providing them the care
that they require
inactive evil and you are seeing medical
professionals cave-ins who political
correctness specifically because they
don't want to buck up against the
prevailing political winds there's a
reason that you are seeing the number of
people identifying as transgender
skyrocketing across the world I mean
skyrocketing in Britain skyrocketing in
the United States Britain has a huge
gender Youth clinic sorry it is now
around apparently in 2009 they took in
one hundred kids a year in 2009 at this
huge Youth clinic in Britain now they
are taking in twenty five hundred kids a
year do you think that is a natural
reflection of biology or do you think
that maybe this has to do with the
politically correct notion that if your
kid is gender identity confused that the
best thing you can do is immediately get
them into a program that reinstalls the
the confusion Sky News reported hundreds
of young transgender people are now
seeking help to return to their original
sex but you're not allowed to talk about
any of this in the in the general
medical community if you do you are
considered a science denier Psychology
Today published that study I talked
about before where with the hike with
the Harvard psychiatrist and medical
researcher Jack turbine write published
the summary a bunch of medical
professionals push push their critiques
in the comments Psychology Today simply
deleted their comments this is all
misinformation or a huge percentage of
it is in misinformation but as long as
you pretend that it's science you can
pretend that people who stand in favor
of actual biological science are the
actual science deniers and that their
children should eventually be removed
from them by the way if you think that
that's a scare tactic I promise you it's
already coming to Canada and it is not
long before it comes to the United
States as well these sorts of cultural
wars do matter you saw this in
james-younger in Texas it's gonna come
to the rest of the country it will if
the social left has its way the radical
social left I would imagine even most
liberals don't believe in this sort of
nonsense but the media do and so they
will continue to push it in a second
we'll get to more bad science being
pushed as virtue in just one say first
let's talk about why you need to protect
your data have you ever wondered why
internet access is so much cheaper these
days like 30 or 40 bucks a month it's
because Internet service providers
aren't just making money off the
subscription fees very often they're
making money from knowing your internet
activity and then selling your data to
big text they can monetize that say -
well that tech that that data belongs to
you also they're hackers they're looking
for your information they want it to the
dickin grab
credit-card and then use it to buy nice
things for themselves why should you
hand over that information instead you
should protect that information with
expressvpn as we speak right now there's
a huge fight going on in Congress where
ISPs are lobbying against encrypted DNS
in browsers encryption makes it much
harder to spy on you
ISPs don't want that well the best way
to make sure that 100% of your data is
encrypted from that ISP is with Express
VPN because expressvpn effectively
creates a secure tunnel between all your
devices and the internet so everything
you do online is encrypted not even your
isp can track and collect data on you
expressvpn does work on all your devices
smart phone works on your smart TV on
your tablet you need to protect your
data protect it and expressvpn comm /ban
visit expressvpn comm slash been to get
three extra months of expressvpn
protection at for free that's expressvpn
comm slash been to learn more okay
meanwhile speaking of bad science being
pushed in the name of virtue over the
weekend
something incredibly stupid happened so
there is a harvard-yale football game
Hey hundreds of climate change activists
swarmed the field during halftime of the
football game they delayed the action
for nearly an hour as students chanted
okay boomer while police made arrests
and issued summonses for disorderly
conduct
absolute stupid idiocy here's a little
bit of the video what it looked like
[Music]
student
students sitting on the field in middle
of the field people shearing off so much
virtue insane levels of virtue there
they are on the field at the Yale
Harvard game striking on behalf of no
one understands striking on behalf of
what protesters sat at the 50-yard line
at the Yale Bowl in New Haven
Connecticut arms linked and chancing his
banners echoed calls for urgent change
championed by lawmakers and activists
around the country this is an emergency
one sign read yes I am sure that we are
going to deprive third world peoples of
their access to carbon-based fuels
because a bunch of privileged yuppies
who go to Yale and Harvard tell other
privileged yuppies at Yale and Harvard
they need to cut their investment in
carbon fuels absolute idiocy a Yale
spokesperson expressed disapproval of
the interruption a Harvard
representative said the school
respectfully disagrees with divestment
activists over how to confront climate
change naturally the students were
thrilled the administration allowed this
to go on by the way the Yale authority
should have immediately arrested
everybody because that is just a public
act of criminality and I promise you if
that had been 500 kids rushing the field
to protest on behalf of not aborting
babies they would been arrested within 5
seconds and you wouldn't get the large
cheers officials asked protesters to
leave very nicely they always have to be
very delicate with these kids another
100 students unaffiliated with the
divest movement walked onto the field to
join them some fans booed said the
protests humiliated the schools because
it did Chuck krummy 68 who attended to
get him with his son of former Yale
football player said they're all
supposed to be intelligent people looks
like there's a lot of common sense
missed their generation goes to show
this generation is all about themselves
and not a football game
Roy Emmanuel s'en said of Yale which
entered the game 81 they're playing for
the Ivy League title here maybe costing
the Ivy League championship by the way
because of this delay which lasted an
hour the game almost had to be called on
behalf of darkness because they don't
have lights at this stadium police
arrested the protesters they didn't plan
to leave the field any other way they
want to show that they are really real
heroes real heroes they're just like MLK
going to going to Birmingham jail that's
that's that's exactly what's happening
here New Haven police didn't provide
comment the protest caused a delay of
little over an hour and cause the game
which went into double overtime to end
in your darkness because the Yale Bowl
does not have light naturally what you
saw is a bunch of Democrats cheering
this thing
advocates of divestment have
impatience as school officials say true
independence from fossil fuels is
impossible to achieve and argue they can
use their positions and shareholders to
sway companies practices
apparently they want Yale and Harvard to
stop investing in any company that uses
fossil fuels which is to say all the
companies hey Harvard's captain then
virtue signaled over all of this of
course Harvard's captain in Harvard
wasn't competing for the IVA the
championship however stinks this year
from what I can say and I say that as a
Harvard Law alum here's Harvard's
captain talking about how vital it was
for students to delay a Harvard Yale
football game to demonstrate the climate
change is bad and the Sun is bad and
people using carbon fossil fuels is bad
at this moment both fart institutions
continue to invest in the industries
destroying our futures and when it comes
to the climate crisis Noland wins
Harvard and Yale can't claim to truly
promote knowledge a lot at the same time
supporting the companies engaged in
misleading the public smearing academics
and denying the truth that's why we're
joining together with our friends at
Yale to call for change in solidarity
with my friends at fossil fuel
divestment and fossil for Yale who
disrupted today's proceedings many of my
teammates and I are wearing orange
wristbands the color of the divest
movement after the game we're coming
together to call Palm Presidents Macau
and salivate to the divest from the
fossil fuel industry now for the sake of
our generation really for the sake of
your generation gonna divest from fossil
fuels what does he think it took to make
the iPhone that he's presumably speaking
into he's wearing a Nike shirt do you
think Nike might use a little bit of
fossil fuels just a little bit the whole
thing it's absurd it's absurd none of
this is designed to actually accomplish
anything it's all designed to virtue
signal on behalf of crap solutions that
don't actually accomplish what they seek
to accomplish the same people who are
pushing this kind of stuff say that we
can't use natural gas which has been
solely responsible in the United States
for every decline in emissions and also
we are not supposed to use nuclear power
which would be the other available
alternative it's just silliness Lee the
Harvard has about thirty nine billion
dollars of endowment investment in
fossil fuels and Harvard faculty members
are calling for divestment from all of
that but of course that would require
basically divesting from every major
company because all major companies have
at least some investment in fossil fuels
all absolute silly towns nonsense but
again we'll get to the democratic
central candidates pushing this stuff
you want to make Trump president forever
this is a pretty good way of doing it
I'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about how you stay
connected to your home from anywhere so
I am a safety fanatic not just because
I'm a public figure I've always been a
bit of a safety nut my wife is certainly
very safety conscious and that means
that she is constantly wanting to see
who exactly is at our house well what
about one we're both out of town or what
about when we are just away from the
home and somebody rings the doorbell
well good news this is what ring comes
in I can see who's on my property at all
times ring helps you stay connected from
anywhere so if there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor you'll
get an alert you'll be able to see here
and speak to them all from your phone if
you're on the go this season whether
it's across town or across the country
you can check in anytime for some
much-needed personal peace of mind again
I love ring we have a ring of security
all around our property as a listener
you have a special holiday offer on that
ring welcome kit available right now
with a ring video doorbell - and a chime
Pro the ring welcome kit has everything
that you need to keep an eye on home no
matter what this holiday season brings
with ring you're always at home just
head on over to ring calm /ban that is
ring calm /ban additional terms may
apply ring calm /ban make sure that your
property is protected that you know
about it go to ring comm /a Ben ok in
just a second we're gonna get to the
rest of these virtue signaling by these
Democrat crazies and then we'll get to
the 2020 race where Michael Bloomberg is
jumping in but you can't do that until
you subscribe and they're a bunch of
reasons to subscribe so for example if
you haven't been listening to Andrew
Clayton's fantasy podcast another
Kingdom you need to go to Daley wire.com
right now and subscribe to catch up
because today at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific Andrew and Michael moles will be
sitting down together to discuss the
final season
they will also take subscriber questions
live from the fans this live event will
be free for everyone to watch on
Facebook and YouTube only subscribers
will be able to ask the questions over
at daily wire.com so go check them out
right now also if you're not a
subscriber you're really missing out
head on over to daily wire.com slash
subscribe for as little as 10 bucks a
month you get the articles ad free you
get our live broadcast our full show
library select bonus content that
exclusive daily wire app which is indeed
awesome in if you choose the new All
Access plan you get all of those things
and the legendary leftist ears tumblr ah
so good that Elizabeth Warren badly
copied it just like she did her health
care plan from Bernie Sanders you also
get our brand-new ask me anything
style discussion feature that allows you
to engage our
writers special guests on a weekly basis
so stop depriving yourself come join the
fun over daily wire.com slash subscribe
make the magic happen at for yourself I
mean Thanksgiving is this week christmas
is coming it makes a great gift for
anybody go get the daily wear
subscription now join the team
we're the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so Yael has already divested
partially from fossil fuels but its
chief investment officer David Swensen
said that overhauling the university's
investment portfolio would be foolish
because quote we would all die if fossil
fuel production stopped which it's true
that's true he said every one of us in
the room is a consumer also true the
whole thing is idiotic and the fact that
Yale authorities went along with it the
fact at Yale let these kids stop the
game for an hour to be obnoxious it's
it's pretty ridiculous on its face but
this is what we do now this is what we
do as we'll see in a second the left
loves disrupting cultural events to push
stupid politics so Bernie Sanders was
super happy with all this well first of
all Bernie one's dancing over the
weekend I just had to play this tape
because Bernie dancing is always a sight
to behold here is the the geriatric
socialist cutting the cutting the rug
tripping the light fantastic at one of
his campaign stops it is a thing that
actually happened my favorite is one who
sort of loses the beat and things start
to get very awkward so that's gonna
happen any second - there we go now he's
now he's just like I don't even know why
I'm here man Bernie Bernie just cuttin
loose from 1932 good stuff well he's
waited support for these idiot
protesters he tweeted out that he was
very happy with them he tweeted when
people when people come together to
stand up for justice we win you're gonna
have to explain how people win because a
bunch of people stopped a football game
congratulations to the go people demand
a sustainable future for our planet we
are with you in this fight by the way
all those young people you know what
they can do today then give up those
Harvard and Yale scholarships for third
world people who wish to come here and
not engage in fossil fuel use the rest
of their lives they can do that or
alternatively they can pretend that they
are very virtuous while they go down
there and selfie themselves with their
iPhones created with the use of fossil
fuels who lien cows are the most
irrelevant of all possible Democratic
candidates said from the March for our
lives to worldwide climate strikes
students and young people are leading
the charge to protect their futures I'm
inspired by their efforts to hold their
universities to a higher standard oh
well are you inspired or I just
pandering to young people who don't know
what they're talking about Tom Styer who
has blown something like 300 or less I
heard it was like a
a hundred million dollars on his
quixotic presidential campaign and it
currently has zero percent support he
says these students have it right nobody
wins when were complicit and climate
injustice institutions like Harvard and
Yale must be leaders in the fight to
address the climate crisis really I mean
they're doing all the research and then
you've got a OC who naturally with her
with her massively impressive degree
from bu and economics tweets activism
disrupts the present to change the
future with an emoji of a globe wow she
used a globe emoji guys she's serious
she's very serious that's globe emoji
you know what that means
that means that she that means that
she's thought this one through activism
disrupts the president to change the
future any other any other Nostrum Xand
truisms you'd like to dump on us here
koc absolute genius I mean things this
sort of stuff is why it's almost
impossible to take many climate change
activists seriously they don't provide
solutions yes I did a speech at Boston
at Ashley this one is at Baylor
University last week when the speech at
Baylor University I spent probably
fifteen minutes talking about climate
change I talked about possible solutions
and one of the things that I talked
about is the fact that according to the
left there's no need for a solution this
is all about yelling at the problem it
was just yell at the problem that it's
gonna go away
so if you show up at a Yale Harvard
football game and you yell at the
problem and magically it gets better but
this is what so many on the radical left
desire they don't want solutions they
just want to yell about problems and
then they want to claim that they're
victims when people point out that what
they are doing is dumb if you point out
that this was a dumb protest that
delayed a football game and nearly led
Yale to lose its Ivy League championship
which you know look in the grand scheme
of things that a big deal no but there
are players on the field it's a football
game it's not time for your climate
activism you want to do climate activism
sit sit outside the stadium you don't
get plenty of attention but by
disrupting and then being cheered on by
Democrats this is the same kind of
garbage that students were doing in the
1960s taking over universities and the
authorities were basically sitting there
allowing people who are disrupting to
prop their feet up on the desks and take
over administration's
you wonder why more and more Americans
look skeptically at college this would
be the reason but that's not the limit
of the of the support for dumb activism
Tonica see Coates has an incredible
piece in the New York Times today called
the cancellation of Colin Kaepernick
Donaghy
it's the would be James Baldwin who
can't write or speak nearly as well as
James Baldwin and happens to live off
the fat of the land while complaining
about how terrible America is I mean
that dude is doing just fine he's
writing comic books for mainstream
audiences they're not very good by the
way and complaining about how America is
terrible but but praised because
obviously he writes with purple passion
Coates has a piece called the
cancellation of Colin Kaepernick in
which he likens Colin Kaepernick to
Muhammad Ali who lest it be forgotten
while several years of his career -
protesting at the Vietnam War he likens
him to Jack Johnson who was banned from
boxing for the great sin of being
involved in an interracial relationship
Colin Kaepernick was benched for Blaine
Gabbert in 2015 because he stunk let the
immortal Hall of Fame NFL player Blaine
Gabbert he was benched for him and then
a few months later he decided you know
I'm gonna do I'm gonna kneel for the
national anthem and then he's made
millions of bucks off of it and then
over the last couple of weeks he played
this game with the NFL where the NFL
offered him basically a combine tryout
and he proceeded to ignore them hold his
own combine tryout and then suggest that
he was so good in the combine try out
that only racism could explain why he
wasn't being signed by an NFL team well
maybe it's the fact they're not very
good and you're a pain in the ass maybe
it's those two things combined a Manny
Ramirez can be a pain in the ass in told
Manny is no longer hitting 330 Colin
Kaepernick can be a pain in the ass so
long as he is not one of the worst
quarterbacks in the league at that point
you lose your job so Tony he's he coats
it's a long piece today about how Colin
Kaepernick is a victim of American and
society and he compares him to I to be
Wells Paul Robeson who is a singer who's
a black communist and also was
blackballed because of his communism and
the Dixie Chicks who by the way made a
deliberate choice to go extremely
political in the country music realm
what did they think was going to happen
I mean Tony he sequence is so over the
top his column every one of his columns
is basically comparing two things that
are completely unelect he literally
compares Colin Kaepernick to the
compromise of 1877 which ended
reconstruction in the south he called
that canceled culture that wasn't
canceled culture what is he even talking
about I'm not a fan of canceled culture
what happened to Colin Kaepernick is not
in any way similar to the compromise of
1877 which led to a century of Jim Crow
and running roughshod of the KKK and
lynching what is he talking about
he he commands Colin Kaepernick to
detention of japanese-americans during
World War two he says speaking as one
who has felt the hot wrath of Twitter ah
he's a victim too
I'm not without sympathy for the morally
panik's who fear their kids are not
right who are not are not all right but
it is good to remember that every every
wildwood that while every generation
believes in invented sex every preceding
generation forgets it once believed the
same thing
besides all cancellations are not
created equal Christine Blasi Ford who
accused Brett Kavanaugh at his supreme
court confirmation hearings of sexual
assault was inundated with death threats
forced from her home driven into hiding
Dave Chappelle accused of transphobia
collected millions from Netflix for a
series of stand-up specials and got his
feelings hurt first of all nobody
canceled Christina Blasi Ford that's a
bunch of evil people targeting people
with death threats nobody's in favor of
that the point with Dave Chappelle is
that the canceled culture trying to come
after Dave Chappelle was idiotic because
he's a man who tells jokes but what
happened to Colin Kaepernick is not
canceled culture the man was given a
million dollar contract with Nike to
meal for the national anthem and suck at
football and now he's complaining about
sucking at football but Tana he see
Coates again this is all virtue
signaling as they substitute for actual
virtue Donaghy C code says it seems mr.
Kaepernick's in refusing to stand for
the national anthem offends the NFL's
suddenly delicate sensibilities the NFL
let him kneel for a year and a half and
let everyone else in the NFL kneel to
the NFL didn't punish anyone for
kneeling the NFL allowed NFL players to
run out on the field in the middle of
the Michael Brown scenario shouting
hands up don't shoot with their hands in
the air which was a total and complete
lie slandering police officers across
America but Coates says while the
influence of hashtags should not be
underestimated the NFL has a different
power at its fingertips the power of
monopoly effectively mr. Kaepernick's
cancellation bars him from making a
living at a skill he has been honing
since childhood it is true his found
gainful employment with Nike but only so
much solace can be taken in this given
that mr. Kaepernick's opponents occupy
not just boardrooms and owner boxes but
the White House well so do his head so
do his friends
town EGC Coates is doing just fine and
he's helping out Colin Kaepernick again
Nike is one of the world's biggest
companies he says a sobering
process that began with the broadcast
beatings of civil rights marchers at
Edmund Pettus Bridge in Selma in 1965
and accelerated with the recorded police
brutality against Rodney King has
achieved its zenith with the social
media sharing of the executions of
Walter Scott laQuan McDonald and Daniel
shaver are we really comparing all of
these things and we're comparing those
to Colin Kaepernick he says the
Newcastle culture is the product of a
generation born into a world without
obscuring myth where the great abuses
once only hinted at suspected or uttered
on street corners are now tweeted out in
full-color nothing is sacred anymore and
most important nothing is legitimate
least of all those institutions charged
with dispensing justice and so justice
is seized by the crowd he says this is
suboptimal but the choice would now seem
to be between building egalitarian
institutions capable of withstanding
public scrutiny or further retreat into
a dissembling fog it's funny to hear
Donaghy zcode say this
Donaghy Coates was one of the chief
editors over at the Atlantic when they
decided to cancel my friend Kevin
Williamson for the great sin of being
pro-life but he's saying we need a gala
terian institutions willing to stand up
to the canceled culture except it
depends on which part of the cancel
culture he opposes oh man the virtuous
signaling is strong with this one but
again the virtue signaling is all about
how America sucks so that's real virtue
okay meanwhile 2020 race heating up man
it there's some very hot news over the
weekend and obviously disturbing news
over the weekend Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg who I am NOT a fan of obviously
I think every ruling that she has issued
in a major case has been wrong she was
treated for chills and fever over the
weekend and discharged from the hospital
she's now 86 she's had a series of
health scares in the past year her
symptoms apparently abated after
treatment with IV antibiotics and fluids
she had surgery for lung cancer and
radiation for pancreatic cancer in the
past year if something were to happen to
her I mean the tenor of American
politics which is always so incredibly
high would just skyrocket dramatically
meanwhile Michael Bloomberg is jumping
into the race and Michael Bloomberg has
said has set some rules for Bloomberg
News covering him and covering the the
presidential race which should tell you
where all of these news organizations
were from the very beginning because the
only thing that's wrong with what
Michael Bloomberg's news organization
has to say
how covers the race is that Michael
Bloomberg is now being honest about it
so first here's Michael Bloomberg's ad
for the presidency he's released his
first ad he's gonna spend a boatload of
his own money in order to start
garnering some support the person
hardest hit if Michael Bloomberg should
start to garner some support could
theoretically be Joe Biden but I think
probably he cannibalizes peabody judge
instead here's here's Michael Bloomberg
his first ad Mike Bloomberg started as a
middle-class kid who had to work his way
through college then built a business
from a single room to a global entity
creating tens of thousands of
good-paying jobs along the way he could
have stopped there but when New York
suffered the terrible tragedy of 9/11 he
took charge becoming a three-term mayor
who brought a city back from the ashes
and brought back jobs and hoped with it
Mike Bloomberg for president jobs
creator leader problem solver it's going
to take all three to build back a
country okay so the fact is Bloomberg's
going nowhere in this race but his
presence in the race does shake things
up if he starts to gain at least a
little bit of support from the
institutional investors who might go to
Biden or who might otherwise go to
Buddha judge okay meanwhile Bloomberg
News has announced its policies with
regard to how it's going to cover this
race so they're shutting down Bloomberg
opinion Bloomberg opinion is now shut
down because Michael Bloomberg is
running for president so according to
Bloomberg editor-in-chief John Michael
wait he says the place where Mike has
had the most contact with editorial is
Bloomberg opinion our editorials have
reflected his views
David Shipley Tim O'Brien some members
of the board responsible for those
editorials will take a leave of absence
to join Mike's campaign will suspend the
board there will be no unsigned
editorials but then we get to the best
part so Bloomberg's newsroom is now
overtly saying corn the editor in chief
the newsroom will not be investigating
Bloomberg and they will extend the same
policy to his rivals in the Democratic
primaries we cannot treat Mike's
Democratic competitors differently from
him
for the moment our investigations team
will continue to investigate the Trump
administration as the government of the
day if Mike is chosen as the Democratic
presidential candidate and Trump emerges
as the Republican one we will reassess
how to do that okay so in other words
this has always been a tool of Michael
Bloomberg and the line between news and
editorial was never clear because if it
were really clear they would have just
said listen we're going to keep
reporting on everybody including Michael
Bloomberg because the line between news
and editorial has always been clear but
they are now openly admitting that the
newsroom was not separate from the
editorial room so now the newsroom has
been specifically tasked with not
investigating Michael Bloomberg which
means they can't investigate any of the
other Democrats because otherwise it
becomes a partisan tool right then they
have to admit that this was always
Michael Bloomberg's tool the newsroom
and so they're saying we just won't go
after the Democrats but we'll continue
to go after Trump which means now this
is a democratic newspaper right I mean
that's the only way to read this michael
Thwaite says I think this is a structure
that can cope with many eventualities no
doubt many of you are already thinking
of possible complexities that may arise
my response is let's get back to work we
can spend a long time debating what-ifs
I'd rather we got on with the journalism
and let that speak for itself
pretty incredible pretty incredible that
they are now pushing Bloomberg is now
saying we will investigate Trump we will
not investigate any Democrat because
Bloomberg is a Democrat and we can't
investigate him so he won't investigate
any of the other Democrats it's an
amazing amazing statement about where
the media are because we know that this
is the same thing happening at the New
York Times right we know this is the
same thing happening at the Washington
Post we at the Daily wear are honest
enough to admit our biases and explain
that the division between news and
editorial is not a solid line that there
is opinionated news that goes in okay
but Bloomberg News didn't say that for
years for years it was this is an
objective news source Bloomberg News and
get the same thing from the New York
Times the same thing from the Washington
Post and this statement completely blows
all of that up because again it is now
Michael Bloomberg's newspaper admitting
we are not going to investigate Michael
Bloomberg because he owns us and so we
won't investigate any of the Democrats
because that wouldn't be fair and then
maybe if if he's the nominee and then so
what what if he isn't the nominee they
go back to investigating the Democrats
is that the way that this works pretty
astonishing stuff meanwhile by the way
Pete Buddha judge is about to get the
Elizabeth Warren treatments he's been
climbing in the polls and now he is
going to be targeted at the center of
this 2020 campaign because he's leading
in Iowa and New Hampshire Meet the Press
went after bootie judge over the weekend
expect from many more attacks like this
in the coming weeks she's reinforcing a
point that many people have made you
can't engage in an oppression derby the
Jews the blacks the Italians the game
whatever Durbin somebody always feels if
you ain't in Kentucky it's bad so what's
interesting is that she also had to deal
with the the the gauntlet they've been
thrown down is that black people are
more gay I mean more homophobic right so
now you're thinking if I come at him
then it reinforces the perception of
black people being my home more
homophobic
okay so again this is gonna be a real
problem for people who to judge prepare
for Buddha judge to take a turn at the
bottom of the heap alright time for some
things I like and then we'll get to some
things that I hate so things that I like
today so there's a fairly solid
understanding in most American
historical writing that America's
founding was Diaz that most of the major
American founders were deists who didn't
necessarily believe in the in the
specific the specifics of Christianity
this is certainly true of Benjamin
Franklin and Thomas Jefferson and mostly
true of John Adams as well but there
were a bunch of founders who obviously
were deep and believing Christians and
of course even the deists were heavily
involved in a philosophy of Christianity
even if they did not believe in some of
the miraculous claims of Christianity
that was certainly true of John Adams
who said that the Constitution was
written for a moral and religious people
and was utterly inadequate to the cause
of any other there's a good new book out
by Mark David Hall from Thomas Nelson
called did America have a Christian
founding that sort of takes the other
side of the view that America did in
fact have a Christian founding now my
own view of this is that the the
Christian roots the judeo-christian
historical and moral roots of the
founding are fairly obvious that the
founding of America yes was based on the
writings of John Locke and the writings
of Montesquieu but it was also based on
an underlying ethos that was derived
from both a notion of British
citizenship and from a judeo-christian
ethic that was prevalent in the United
States and in the West at the time and
that the American Revolution was not
designed to forcibly separate the
American people from those
judeo-christian ethics in fact it was
designed to Wed them to the ethics in
the social sphere while allowing
government to operate free of religious
bigotry at the top level the book is
definitely an interesting source it did
America have a Christian founding my
mark at David Hall and worth reading
along with a book that I recommended
last week about America's revolutionary
mind by C Bradley Thompson that those
are both interesting interesting books
okay other things that I you know let's
just let's do a quick thing that I hate
so the New York Times is now suggesting
that there has been a vast spike in
support for a public option because a
lot of voters are not interested in
Medicare for all the Democrats of course
are pushing Medicare for all incredibly
hard but a bunch of Democrats are
realizing that this is a big mistake and
so they've been pushing for the
so-called public option so we need to
explain what the public option is and
why the public option is a bad idea
Republicans push very hard against a
public option in Obamacare many
Democrats were not comfortable with a
public option in Obamacare why well a
public option basically suggests that if
you are not employed then you're
immediately enrolled in Medicare this
creates two separate problems problem
number one employers now have an
interest in downgrading you to part x
that you are covered by medicare and
then they don't have to take care of
your medical insurance to the people who
are most likely to end up on on a public
option are the people who are the
sickest and the oldest and require the
most care which means that they are not
risk pooled with other people it means
that private insurance is going to be up
charged by doctors in order to
compensate for the fact that Medicare
tends to under charge Medicare's
reimbursement rates are somewhere from
60 to 80 percent private insurances is
somewhere over a hundred percent usually
and and what that means is that if you
are in the private insurance sector your
costs will go up as the public option
grows either you'll have to pay
additional tax dollars in order to pay
for all of the new people who are on the
public option or you will have to pay
through additional premiums and then one
of two things happens either the public
option is real crap in other words it's
not as good as the private option
doctors don't take it doctors either
have to be forced to take it right which
is a cramdown or doctors are not forced
to take it in which case a lot of
doctors decide they are not going to
work with the public option because it
under charges them right under in under
delivers in terms of their payments in
which case again they either have to be
forced or the government has to raise
the reimbursement rates if the
government raises reimbursement rates to
the point where it's competitive with
private insurance then they will then
the government and Democrats and
employers will use that as an excuse to
push for a single-payer health care
system at which point when everybody is
thrown onto the single-payer health care
system then the entire system that goes
back to being a system of scarcity so
you could see is the government rev up
spending on a public option in order to
compete with the private option the
option goes defunct through regulation
and through mandates and at that point
we have a single-payer health care
system at which point the spending
ratchets back down and you end up with
all of the evils of Medicare for all so
it's always been seen by most analysts
the public option as step one toward a
medicare-for-all system well Democrats
are pushing this right now because they
understand that the final outcome is not
something Americans want they get that
Americans are not pleased with the idea
being thrown off their private insurance
so instead they're looking for a
step-by-step approach according to the
New York Times they believe that this is
going to gain credibility the New York
Times says the proposal would allow
people of all incomes who aren't old
enough for Medicare to choose health
coverage through a new government-run
plan that would compete with private
insurance known by the less than catchy
shorthand public option that means again
the only people who are actually going
to enter this public option are going to
people be people who are too sick to get
private insurance people who are
unemployed or if the public option is
really ramped up people who are who are
pushed into the public option because
the public option is actually really
good for the moment and then private
insurance collapses there's no reason
for competition than the monopoly kicks
in a decade ago the issue created such
deep internal divisions among Senate
Democrats they ultimately dropped the
idea from their bill even though the
public option is strongly favored by
many liberals and a majority of House
Democrats but now it seems as though a
public option is looking like a safe
moderate position and even a realistic
policy goal according to the New York
Times Warren says that she would start
her presidency by pushing for a public
option about two-thirds of voters liked
the idea of a public option or a
Medicare buy-in according to several
recent national polls until they are
told about the cost of course large
majorities of Democrats and independents
favored a public option in kaisers
November poll why because they think
someone else is gonna be on the public
option not them they think I'll get to
keep my Medicare my medical insurance it
won't cost me more money yeah it's going
to cost you more money either through
taxes or through your upcharge private
insurance which is used again to pay the
doctors we're mandated to take the
public option dr. Alexandra Argos insky
56 an internist buttonholed Biden about
his plan and Concord said I think our
goal should be to try to get everybody
in America to have health insurance I
think the easiest and fastest way is
what Biden is proposing to have the
public option polls suggest voters have
become unnerved as the New York Times by
the pricetags of the Warren and Sanders
Medicare for all plans support for such
an approach has narrowed in recent
months as people begin to under
and what it would actually involve a
Kaiser Family Foundation poll of voters
in Michigan miss at Minnesota
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin found that
62% of those who are undecided are still
persuadable believe a national Medicare
for all plan that would eliminate
private insurance is a bad idea
sixty-two percent 62 percent the public
option plans offered by Biden and Budaj
Edgewood require much less federal
spending and then Warren's 21 trillion
dollar proposal by the way that's a wild
under estimate it would actually cost
somewhere in the neighborhood of 33
trillion Biden says his plan will cost
750 billion over ten years
Buddah jej says it would cost 1.5
trillion it would cost a lot more than
that because there is never yet been a
government spending program that was
under estimated and that was
overestimated in terms of cost rather
Biden and Budaj hedges plans would
automatically enrolled uninsured
Americans into the new government health
plan and allow anyone else to opt in if
they wish both candidates would offer
more generous premium subsidies than the
Obama care provides and cap people's
premium costs at eight point five
percent of their income people would
with premium subsidies would have
deductibles of about a thousand dollars
or less so basically there would be a
very small opt in mandate your premium
cost would be eight point five percent
of your income which is not going to pay
for the amount that's going to be taken
out of a public option obviously Warren
is proposing it overtly as a bridge she
says that it'll be there for three years
and then everybody's gonna love it so
much that they're gonna opt into
Medicare for all yeah good luck good
luck but the fact is even the public
option is a bad option the public option
has long been seen again as a first step
toward nationalized health care and
trying to play it as some sort of a as a
wonderful idea that is popular with the
American people is is is really it's a
stretch it's a stretch but everything
looks moderate I mean once you once you
get to the the point where a public
option is seen as moderate you've gone
too far to the left and everybody sort
of acknowledges that a public option is
a bad idea
Seema Verma is administrator of the
Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
Services she has an editorial from July
called I'm the administrator of Medicaid
and Medicare a public option is a bad
idea this according to the Washington
Post right she's
a common proposal the public option
would introduce a government-run plan
into the commercial health insurance
market or alternatively allow consumers
under 65 to buy into Medicare simply
calling something moderate doesn't make
it so
as an administrator of the two largest
public healthcare programs in the
country Medicare and Medicaid I can say
these programs face major fiscal
challenges those who seek to expand them
and do so because of their expected
lower price tag on premiums but there's
a simple explanation that makes the low
cost considerably less alluring public
programs pay healthcare providers less
than private payers according to a study
in Health Affairs private insurance in
2012 paid hospitals approximately 75
percent more than Medicare did for
similar inpatient services Medicaid
payment rates were even lower than
Medicare rates that's why a substantial
proportion of providers 30 percent don't
accept new patients on Medicaid rather
than expand public programs for future
generations Americans are more
interested in protecting the viability
of these programs into the future first
further low prices imposed on doctors
and hospitals can't stop healthcare
costs from rising and they continuously
do because someone has to pay the bill
namely everybody in the private
insurance market at the same time a
public option is backed by the federal
government which creates a host of
problems public options can turn to
taxpayers to bail them out but private
players have no such luxury
so they have to compete for consumers
but without market pressure on the
bottom line and expand a government plan
with balloon uncontrollably crowd out
private option options push consumers
off private plans and reduce choice as
private plans that flee the market which
of course is exactly what's going to
happen and this is the plan so anybody
who sees Budi dredgen Biden's plan is
some sort of moderate trade-off is just
getting the answer wrong it is not
correct okay we'll be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
see him the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 on the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you